it's been almost six years since
civilization 5 released don't you think
we're about due for a sequel well it's
happening and it's bringing some big
changes I'm Tony and this is your highly
civilized gamespot news update
civilization 6 is led by the designers
of civ 5 s expansions gods and kings and
brave new world but unlike in that game
where city stack on a single hex tile
sip 6 spreads out onto multiple tiles
because of this each city can specialize
and make use of different terrains and
resources it also means you can raid
specific districts of your opponent's
towns instead of targeting one big
metropolis you'll have to decide which
districts to defend too and when it
comes to research you can reach smaller
milestones that raise your science
capabilities and specific areas with all
of these changes sip sixes campaigns
should play out differently every time
civilization 6 comes to pc on october
21st so you only have a few months to
wait before you can watch society rise
and fall over and over again for a more
in-depth preview you can head over to
gamespot com and for all the latest on
civilization you're already in the right
place
you
you